ninomiya name is Juan Diego Zacharias on
23 years old and live in Lima Peru
that made the moment I'm still a student
I'm studying cinematography and would
like to work in the film industry I'd
love to tell stories what a look at that
girl Vanessa Tommy la musica soon
official now I like music I play the
Kahana Peruvian drum laconia there are
so many things you can eat when your
aunt Beru they my love seven chapters
and eating rice with seafood or causa
and lomo saltado a beef stir-fry I could
talk about it until the tape runs
amber dad just living in Peru is a
wonderful thing that I give it all you
can come here to Miraflores or go to
Barranco to enjoy this beautiful
landscape it's relaxing makes you happy
when I something but I be did I now have
few worries me well laugh all day no
having a job not completing what I set
out to achieve like having a family and
finishing my studies look at my wall
semi carrera y aparte I'd like to travel
to europe sometime to England I think
that country has a mystical aura sad we
see that
but i'm eli global economy globalization
means to experience everything from
around the world tourists from all over
the world come here to Miraflores you
can learn so much about their cultures
get a glimpse into their lives yeah but
now the tourists are a great enrichment
akhiyan for anybody